you came so close to getting rid of
Cuzco and taking over his throne but
unfortunately for you you smug you put
your fate in crunked and wound up
disappointed croc was way too young for
you and yet you kept him around for
selfish reasons and he turned out to be
a wannabe villain but don't worry yous
about we found your perfect man and you
two are a match made in hell Disney
villains need love too sure they've
betrayed those closest to them and
committed horrible crimes but deep down
they just want to be accepted for who
they truly are
keep watching to see some of the best
Disney villain couples of all time and
by best we mean worst I think she took
it rather well Sid Phillips and Darla
Sherman Sid Phillips from Toy Story is
known for being one of the worst
villains of all time sure he's just a
kid but he kidnaps toys takes them apart
and creates monstrosity
he doesn't seem to have any friends and
enjoys being a big fish in a small pond
you might think that Sid would have
trouble finding a girlfriend when he
grows up but that just isn't the case
because Darla Sherman from Finding Nemo
is his perfect match these two villains
would wind up in County Jail in no time
governor Ratcliffe and the Evil Queen
governor Ratcliffe from Disney's
Pocahontas is truly one of a kind
he lives for fashion and luxury and
wants a piece of everyone's pie he's
self-entitled and thinks he owns the
ground he walks on he takes what he
wants and ruins lives in the process
which reminds us of another Disney
villain just like Ratcliffe the Evil
Queen from Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs is vain and selfish to a fault
she's obsessed with beauty and waltzes
into Snow White's castle and takes it
for herself these two villains are
perfect for each other
Clayton and Cruella de Vil clean from
Tarzan isn't someone who messes around
he's obsessed with hunting gorillas and
selling them on the black market he's
manipulative cruel and greedy making him
the perfect man for Cruella de Vil
there are no truths Oh
Krewella once is a closet full of
dashing furs and Clayton would hunt day
in and day out to make his woman happy
clean and Cruella are animal cruelty
advocates which is why they deserve each
other
Captain Hook and Ursula Captain Hook
from Disney's Peter Pan isn't a simple
man he's got a grudge that keeps him up
at night and he needs a girlfriend who
was every bit as evil as he is hook his
devious childish and cowardly
which is why Ursula would walk all over
him we all know that Ursula needs to
call the shots and she's got a score to
settle herself Ursula would transform
into Vanessa and convince hook to hunt
mermaids which could be how Ariel's
mother passed away in the first place
dr. facili a and mother Gothel dr.
facili a from The Princess and the Frog
and Mother Gothel from tangled may not
seem like a perfect match at first but
hear us out
first of all faciliate Gothel have
similar vibes and they both share the
same affinity for velvet and burgundy
besides wearing the same colors Gothel
and faciliate are trapped by their
magics if Gothel doesn't use the Sun
drop flower she'll die of old age and if
faciliate doesn't sign any contracts his
friends on the other side will come
knocking these two would totally bond
over their tragic lives Hades and
Maleficent babies from Hercules and
Maleficent from Sleeping Beauty
literally belong together they're
currently divorced but they do have a
beautiful and brave daughter named mal
both Hades and Maleficent value power
which could be what attracted them to
each other after all they're the
strongest Disney villains of all time
the mistress of evil and the Lord of the
underworld started dating in a house of
mouse episode titled Halloween with
Hades Claude Frollo and Lady Tremaine
Judge Claude Frollo from Disney's The
Hunchback of Notre Dame is one of the
most despicable villains in the Disney
verse he hides behind his political
power and wants nothing more than to rid
Paris of gypsies and enslave those
weaker than him
Claude Frollo may have had a crush on
Esmeralda
but he would fall in love with lady
tremaine just like fellow lady tremaine
takes advantage of her status and puts
those weaker than her to work there's
the large carpet in the main clean it
she wants to keep people down in the
dumps and take away their opportunities
these two caretakers are a perfect match
Prince Hans and Drizella Tremaine Prince
Hans of the Southern Isles is obsessed
with titles and castles making him the
perfect suitor for Lady Tremaine
Stoddard Ursula once tried to cheat his
way onto the throne just like Drizella
tried to cheat her way into prince
charmings heart both Hans and Rosalind
know what it means to live in their
sibling shadow which is why sparks would
surely fly between them it's a common
theory that Hans and Drizella got
married after meeting on the Isle of the
lost and had a handful of daughters one
of them being dizzy Tremaine Jafar and
ESMA litigious ironies mohab in common
well for starters they're both Disney
villains who posed as royal advisors and
tried to steal their king's throne right
from underneath them but their
similarities don't end there Jafar yozma
also had crushes on people who were way
younger than them these two sorcerers
would do anything to become royal
subjects but it looks like they'll have
to settle for each other which Disney
villain couple was your favorite tell us
in the comments hit that subscribe
button and give this video a like thanks
for watching the things we'll see you
again soon
[Music]